what does it mean  to be a hero  in the last several years since the  devastation of metropolis the alien  known as superman has been held  responsible for the destruction lexcorp  and wayne industries are working  together to co-finance a new metropolis  their financial strategy is set for the  next several years i was thinking about  what you said to me  i'm at the end of the day not doing more  good than hard  just  silence  what are you gonna do let me warn you  always be the smartest guy in the room  none of us have ever faced a situation  quite like this one before i need your  help  as you very well know that you're a very  important piece of this puzzle it's cow  don't do this please  you're my friend cal i never would have  done this to you  bye